I've had so many regrets about telling
you guys about this I remember sitting
next to Phoebe water bridge I remember
talking to her before the show Jim I'm
gonna tell the story and I don't know
what I don't actually I don't know if
this is because I'm just wondering you
know III don't want be real thing about
because it's great it's quite is this a
bad story and she sort of told me what
the story wasn't I thought this is great
so it's a perfect Graham Norton Show
tale backstage there are some japes with
actors you know sure sure sure
you know you know big keep the other
actors kind of and entertained at when
it's a really long run and I'm really
sorry mum that I'm telling the story and
there was one I was doing hay fever and
it was a three-month run and there was
one moment and it's one moment on the
stage where I was offstage with this
other actor Sam and one of the other
actors played one of the Karen's play by
Freddy Fox would storm across the stage
open this door and we'd be standing
behind the door you know master on the
audience and he had to go and then he
slammed the door and run back onto the
stage and so we always used to do
something kind of quirky behind the door
to make him laugh and every night we
started off by doing a little like Oh
kissing or like oh we put a funny hat on
Sam but it was three months long this
run we had to have the game every night
all night until we started getting the
stage management involved and never
massive like hot dog costumes and
from outside to come into every time
Freddie would open the door he'd be like
really cuz I didn't even like change
really quickly and then run on the stage
and the other cast members could see it
and it was building and building we were
running out of ideas and it's like a
week left and we were exhausting
ourselves and then suddenly it was
getting syn the last night we were like
we have to have a big finish like what
are we gonna do for Freddie and neither
of us to think of anything and suddenly
we did the math name we've done this
kind of wild kinda like spangly glittery
thing and then on the final performance
we have nothing and we were like we have
to do something we have to do something
we could hear Freddie coming across the
stage and we're like we haven't thought
of anything
[Laughter]
pink skirts and Astoria see the London
state Olivia Colman Lindsey Duncan
giving rally all going yeah too far
[Applause]
[Music]
you